over the past few weeks we've talked
about how california has the highest
poverty level in the country and how new
york is the fastest shrinking state in
the country considering the dire state
of these two regions it's not surprising
that a lot of people are looking for a
new home on tv we always hear about
these people moving to texas and florida
but the fastest growing state in the us
in terms of percentage is actually idaho
between july of 2020 and july of 2021
idaho's population grew by 2.9 percent
this is nearly three times higher than
the growth rate of texas and florida
this isn't some new phenomenon either
idaho has consistently topped the growth
charts over the past 10 years since 2011
idaho's population has grown by over 20
percent while even texas population has
only grown by 15
now of course texas has a far greater
nominal growth but it's crazy to think
that a state like idaho which is
generally overlooked by most people is
so popular amongst migrants so why are
so many people moving to idaho
starting with the most obvious reason we
have finance
idaho is simply a far more affordable
place to live than much of the country
now idaho isn't dirt cheap like arkansas
or oklahoma but they're definitely on
the reasonable side of things for
example let's take a look at housing
housing prices have actually shot up
quite a bit over the past two years in
idaho even more so than the rest of the
country before the pandemic started the
average house cost three hundred
thousand dollars but now the average
house costs 475 000
this means that idaho housing has shot
up 58 percent over the past two years
but if you scroll back to let's say 2016
the average house cost 211 000
and in 2013 the average house cost 154
000
so as you can see idaho has historically
had cheap housing and even now the
average house in idaho is only slightly
more expensive than the national average
of 440 thousand dollars something else
to consider is that a significant
portion of migrants to idaho come
directly from california in fact
californians have made up 46 of the net
migration to idaho over the past five
years and these guys are not only used
to seeing far more expensive housing
prices but many of them have also earned
california inflated salaries for several
years if not over a decade this is
especially true for tech workers for
someone who's worked at feng as a
software engineer throughout their 20s
buying a house in idaho even with cash
seems pretty realistic it's not just
housing that's affordable either every
facet of life in idaho is cheaper than
most of its western neighbors in fact
idaho is the 19th most affordable place
to live in the u.s for perspective
washington comes in at 38 oregon comes
in at 47 and california comes in at 49.
considering this it's no wonder that
idaho is a top choice for people living
in these states it's not all perfect
though idaho does have some hefty taxes
in fact idaho has one of the highest
state income taxes in the nation coming
in at number six to make things worse
you don't even have to make that much to
fall into the highest tax bracket as
long as you make over seven thousand
nine hundred and forty dollars per year
you have to pay six and a half percent
so this is basically everybody who has a
job
even in california you have to make over
thirty five thousand dollars per year to
pay for the tax rate idaho also has
substantial sales taxes as well coming
in at six percent for perspective that
california sales tax is 7.25
on the bright side though property taxes
are relatively low in idaho the average
resident pays an effective tax rate of
0.69 which works out to roughly 1 500
per year this is one of the places that
idaho shines above even texas texas is
notorious for having high property taxes
to make up for a lack of income tax the
average texan pays an effective property
tax of one point eight percent which
works out to three thousand nine hundred
dollars per year
also something else to note is that
states generally have a cap as to how
much property values can increase in a
given year for example the cap in texas
is 10
this means that even if your property
skyrockets in value by 40
you'd only be taxed 10 more the
following year
so most of these tax assessments haven't
caught up to current home prices once
they do uh idaho will likely just become
even more appealing so while idaho has
its ups and downs financially in the big
picture idaho is far cheaper than most
of the western states that people are
migrating from
aside from offering an affordable life
idaho also offers quite a few career
opportunities you see it it's not just
people that are moving from western
states to idaho but also companies
of course they also benefit from all the
cost savings just like everyone else but
there's more to it than just that idaho
can sometimes be a more desirable
expansion choice than texas due to its
proximity flights between san francisco
and the boise aren't even two hours long
meanwhile flights between austin and san
francisco take nearly four hours idaho's
proximity to california becomes an even
larger advantage if your other options
are new york or florida it takes over
six hours to travel from either of these
places to san francisco considering this
as a business if you need employees to
travel between your offices on a regular
basis it makes a lot of sense to choose
idaho and that's exactly what many tech
companies have done something else to
note is that idaho's proximity makes it
a prime destination for remote workers
even before the pandemic idaho was one
of the leaders in terms of remote work
in fact idaho ranked 6th in the nation
with 5.9 percent of their workforce
working remotely during the pandemic
this number obviously went to the moon
reaching heights of nearly 50
since then companies have been shifting
back to in person but many employees are
choosing to stay remote permanently
sometimes this means shifting to another
company that allows for remote work or
even negotiating a lower salary a tesla
employee named solomon for example
accepted a 20 pay cut to stay in idaho
stories like these have actually become
so common that companies have started
developing streamlined policies for pay
cuts and remote work google for instance
is cutting pay by 5 to 25 based on where
a remote employee moved to
it's not just tech workers that are
having a blast in idaho either
idaho offers plenty of blue-collar jobs
as well a great example is idaho's
lumber industry idaho has the eighth
highest lumber production in the nation
and given how much lumber prices have
gone up over the past two years this has
been quite lucrative a similar case
could be made for idaho's food
processing chemicals paper and mining
industries as well
idaho ranks seventh when it comes to
agricultural goods and food product
exports per capita similarly 45 percent
of all silver mined in the us comes from
idaho and idaho is the second largest
producer of phosphate and this isn't
just cherry picked evidence either there
are stats that show that boise not only
has a strong labor market but the
strongest in the entire nation take job
posting growth for example between
february of 2020 and january of 2022
boise saw the highest growth in job
postings in the nation coming in at an
impressive in 94.8
in other words job opportunities
literally doubled in the past two years
in boise so there's no question that
boise is one of the best places to start
a long-term career right now
[Music]
the two factors that we've discussed so
far alone are likely enough to convince
most people to at least consider idaho
but there are many more factors that
actually push them to make the decision
for example they might be convinced by
idaho's beautiful outdoors while idaho
isn't warm year-round like california
many prefer idaho because it actually
has four distinguishable seasons you can
experience it for winter spring summer
and fall every year
not to mention there's plenty of
activities to do outside thanks to
idaho's largely preserved nature idaho
has over 2 000 named lakes and 4.7
million acres of designated wilderness
they also have plenty of mountains which
makes the state perfect for hiking
mountain biking skiing snowboarding
fishing and so much more
you also don't have to worry about
natural disasters idaho is safe from
earthquakes wildfires floods volcanic
eruptions tsunamis etc
aside from the great outdoors idaho also
benefits from the perks of suburban life
such as safety and schooling starting
with safety idaho has relatively low
crime on average there are 227.1 violent
crimes reported for every 100 000 people
in the state the national average is
380.6 billion crimes per 100 000 people
similarly the state's robbery average
comes in at 11.4 instance per 100 000
people which is the second lowest in the
country these promising statistics carry
over to property crimes as well which
comes in at
1461.4 per 100 000. the national average
is nearly 2200 per 100 000 people
considering all this i don't think you'd
be surprised here that idaho ranks as
the third safest state in the country in
terms of schooling idaho's public school
system is nothing to brag about but it
is respectable
it comes in at right about average in
the country at rank 29 something to note
however is that idaho ranks better than
texas and oregon also the only reason
california ranks better than idaho is
due to their higher education if you
look at k-12 education idaho comes in at
rank 23 while california comes in at
rank 40. so if these are your other
options idaho is actually relatively
good moving on from education idaho is
great for proximity to the west coast
this is not only an advantage for tech
companies located in california but also
an advantage for people with family on
the west coast a lot of times the number
one reason that people don't want to
leave a state like california is because
they have a lot of friends and family
there but given idaho's close proximity
to california it's not that expensive or
difficult to visit on a regular basis
this is one of the main reasons that las
vegas is so popular amongst californians
as well
las vegas doesn't quite have the same
career opportunities as boise though so
for many idahoa is the best compromise
in the end people have been facing
economic pressures from all directions
over the past few years we have high
inflation a supply shortage skyrocketing
home prices rising interest rates and
we're officially in a recession with all
that being said people have been
desperate to find a place with a more
reasonable cost of living it without
having to give up too much for many high
earners like managers and high-level
software engineers the solution has been
moving to texas and florida but for many
everyday people they can feel these
states becoming too expensive as well in
austin for example median home prices
are nearly seven hundred thousand
dollars so many have chosen to move to
the next best thing which seems to be
idaho dozens of secondary tech companies
have moved or expanded to boise which
has made career opportunities abundant
combine this with the low cost of living
diverse weather great outdoors
respectable schooling low crime and
close proximity to the west coast and
it's no wonder why idaho has become so
desirable the sad part though is that
this mass migration has carried over
many of the west coast problems over to
idaho for example boise suffers from the
worst rush hour traffic in the entire
country similarly home prices are almost
crossing five hundred thousand dollars
so it's not clear how much longer boise
will remain the top choice for new
migrants but for the people who moved
there in the past five years and
especially those that moved in right
before the pandemic it looks like they
chose the perfect time to make the move
but only time will tell would you guys
move to idaho comment that down below
also drop a like if you hope that idaho
doesn't get ruined as well and of course
consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider the subscribe and see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you